Hello and welcome to Going Green.
In today's edition, we're in Eastern Maryland,...
...where we're gonna take a look at a unique oyster growing program.
There's more beauty in the oysters than just the pearl.
Take a close look at these babies.
They may look dirty but they're teeming with life.
You see, these are barnacles.
The barnacles are coming out of their shells to feed.
And I guess they haven't figured it out that they're out of the water yet.
They're continuing to feed, pretty soon they'll close up.
Chris Judy is with the Maryland Department of Natural Resources,...
...the state agency that's helping to rejuvenate the Chesapeake Bay's oyster reefs...
...and boost the overall population of the shellfish...
...which has been in decline.
The Marylanders Grow Oysters program was started by Governor O'Malley last year...
...and has a couple of basic features. One is stewardship.
Pier owners, who used their piers for perhaps boats and other things for fun...
...are now using their piers to grow oysters.
Another key component...
...is enhancing the oyster population.